this here we go again so alien covenant
has come out and it is better than
Prometheus or as bad as Prometheus or
better or worse depending on what you
wanted the opinion seems to be mixed on
this thing but what really does seems to
be pretty much the consensus is they
went back to the alien films and did
less of Prometheus and once I realized
that they were doing that at this point
the reviews have confirmed that it is
that is pretty much what they did
I lost absolutely any and all interest
in this thing because we need to stop
making alien movies alien this franchise
was brilliant precisely twice and it was
brilliant those two times for pretty
specific reasons the first one it was
just it was horror and space at a level
of production value and atmosphere and
attention to detail that had just never
been done the inventiveness of the
creature itself and its lifecycle and
the atmosphere of that ship it was
unlike anything else before and it still
holds up a lot of that a lot of those
effects certain attention the
performances the great rapport between
the characters all just across the board
solids all movie aliens works as well
because it scaled it up and it also
shifted genres it is a horror tinged war
movie thematically it's got more in
common with something like Saving
Private Ryan or platoon than it does
with the first alien but it takes all of
that aesthetic and all that visual
richness that that first one had and
just scales the whole thing bigger and
that worked that one time because
really there wasn't too many ways to go
bigger than aliens went and so every
film that they've meant they've made
since then has been trying to recapture
one of those two things they are either
trying to recapture the claustrophobia
of alien or they're trying to recapture
the splendor of aliens in one way or
another and neither of those things work
because it doesn't it just becomes a
retread and the reason alien is one of
the best sequels I mean we're also would
you like alien or aliens better in terms
of ways to follow up it's one of the
best sequels ever made because of the
way was able to expand but everything
since then it's just we hash in alien 3
tried to go back to that first one try
to come cross Republic again there are
moments it doesn't work Alien
Resurrection that who even knows what
they were trying to do with that one
they did triangle baby there were some
interesting ideas but I don't think that
one even knew what it wanted to be alien
vs. predator is fun but it's disposable
for me at the right idea which was to
explore bigger and different ideas
within that world not necessarily
focused completely around the xenomorph
itself unfortunately it watched the
execution of that I feel correct
approach and now we've got a alien
covenant which is just it's just alien
again and that there's no way that we'll
ever have the impact and the weight that
it had originally because now we're just
what it is now it is just gone into the
standard slasher sequel cycle which is
same situation same creature just a new
set of cannon fodder over and over again
and that's that that is diminishing
returns at best and we and each new
entry just keeps devaluing this monster
which I will stand by the greatest
cinematic creature ever put on film and
it just gets devalued with each and
every single and
now does this mean that there's no life
left in this franchise no but I don't
think there's more life than it left on
film because fans of this franchise
might point to some other mediums at
this point they might point to the comic
books which gave us colonial Marines
which was able to you know keep the the
feel of em aliens going or the alien vs.
predator
you know comic books those were able to
do some interesting things in a way that
the movie just didn't chose it chose not
to do or a recent example alien
isolation a game about a lot of fans
really love here's the thing though
those didn't feel repetitive and
redundant because they were taking
things that we had admittedly seen in
film and translating them to another
medium in ways that took advantage of
what that medium did really especially
with alien isolation because if that had
been another film it would have been an
alien retread I mean top to bottom but
from an interactive standpoint and being
able to actually play that and feel
ourselves exploring that ship and
feeling the dread of that alien it
hadn't been done to that level in an
interactive space before with this
property so the shift in the medium was
enough to make it feel fresh again but
the story itself had it been a film ah I
think we all want to turn our noses up
on that and that is what I'm saying
there's nothing of value left in this
franchise on film not with what they're
doing at this point the only thing that
could adjust only would have been
Prometheus because it was going for
something bigger it was expanding ours
it was moving beyond the Xenomorphs
themselves and it was going out into the
greater world to find out what else was
out there
but now alien covenant just shows it as
a reaction to the mixed reception to
Prometheus and again Prometheus had a
lot of problems and I acknowledge all of
that but because fans were like we
wanted to be no more and you know what
I'm sorry sometimes fans we're stupid
and we know what we want but what we
want is in good
we're like a kid eating an entire pint
of ice cream we're going and we're going
to feel sick at the end of all this
we're getting what we want but it's not
a good idea and so when we are when we
want to do more there they and brought
the franchise back to that but what more
is there to get out of the xenomorph and
especially at this point that we're in
prequel territory we're just finding out
more about its origins I don't want to
know about his own I should never know
where this thing came from and why it
exists because you know when it was at
its scariest was that first film and not
just because it was new and surprising
but because as far as that film was
concerned this is just the kind of [ __ ]
that is out there when we go into space
you go into space this is the kind of
stuff you're going to run into we as a
race are not prepared for what is out
there that is the take away of the first
alien and it gets lost every time that
we get this more and more detail more
more info on how these things work and
especially now that we're going to do
where do they come from what creative
apiece an animal nothing to evolve did
this crazy scary thing that I don't like
anything we've seen what is that that is
just that's what's out there we should
be terrified at the idea of these
characters going out in space and got if
this is out there what else might be out
there as far as this franchise is
concerned at this point pretty much
nothing because we keep coming back to
the Xenomorphs over and over and over
and over again and look like I said this
is a brilliant monster it is iconic and
it will always be one of the best
monsters but there's no life left in
this and Ridley Scott is talking about
doing more prequel TBO going on how many
say he's going to do he meets all of
this stop I mean we'll see what this
predator reboot has left in the tank and
then that's not me saying that more
alien versus Predator stuff happens but
look put this franchise to bed
like I said Prometheus on premise
as some potential is squandered it leave
it alone let it die explore all the
other venues all the other mediums that
are out there to keep the franchise
chugging along but stop with the movies
there's nothing left and just remember
in space no one can hear you scream but
on the internet everyone can hear you
scream about geeky stuff that you just
random ramble about or maybe it's just
me so those are my thoughts on the
current state of alien has a franchise
which it shouldn't be anymore what are
your thoughts on all this whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast and/or the
punch like a girl podcast both available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]